in this video I want to talk about the
urea cycle so before we actually talk
about the urea cycle we have to think
about what happens if there's too much
nitrogen around
well we and other organisms need to get
rid of it as simple as that
there's too much nitrogen want to get
rid of it so how did different animals
get rid of nitrogen well some have
ammonia and ammonium which they just
allows you to diffuse away so fish and
amphibians are like that these ammonia
and ammonium ions of course water
soluble they just diffuse away into the
water now we as humans have this thing
called urea hence the name for the urea
cycle we create this compound here two
things that are important about urea
that we want to keep in mind are that
it's non-toxic and that it's water
soluble and we'll talk about why those
two points are important in just a
second now some reptiles and birds get
rid of this product here which is uric
acid so this is for reptiles and birds
and this uric acid is not water-soluble
it's water insoluble but we're not going
to focus too much on that or this we
want to focus on urea so like I
mentioned urea this molecule here is
non-toxic and it's water soluble it's
non-toxic and that makes sense because
this is the way that we're getting rid
of our excess nitrogen our excess
nitrogen specifically is excess ammonium
ion right which is toxic to us so if we
can take an a toxic molecule and
incorporate it into some other molecule
to make it non toxic then we're going to
be able to do that that's a good thing
so that's essentially what's happening
with urea it's also that it's water
soluble that makes sense because we have
to flow through our blood which is of
course mostly water so let's talk about
the overview of the urea cycle the
purpose of course like I mentioned is to
get rid of excess ammonia my are so
basically is getting rid of
toxic compound which is basically
detoxification so this excess ammonium
ion travels through the blood to the
liver specifically where the urea cycle
occurs
now this ammonium ion is carried through
the blood by glutamate or going to mean
with in the form of those amino groups
on these compounds so now once it's in
the liver the excess ammonium will join
carbon dioxide and along with some ACP
to make this molecule here which is
called carbamoyl phosphate so this
carbamoyl phosphate the red portions
that I've drawn the amino group here in
this carbonyl group come from the
ammonium ion and the carbon dioxide
respectively and this phosphate cut one
comes from the ATP the enzyme that
catalyzes this step is called the
carbamoyl phosphate synthetase one or
cps one and this enzyme is basically
regulated in such a way to control the
amount of ammonium or excess nitrogen
that flows and into the urea cycle after
being created after a carbonyl phosphate
is created so essentially once I cover
on a phosphate is created it goes to the
urea cycle and the urea cycle has a
bunch of different energy it's a few of
which I've drawn here this one here you
should recognize as a particular amino
acid so the amino group here carboxyl
group here and this R R group here
this is a spar take this thing here this
intermediate you should recognize as an
intermediate of another pathway the TCA
cycle this thing is called fumarate of
course the end product is this urea here
so notice I've drawn it some portions
right in some portions blue the red
portions are to indicate that this this
portion this red portion here came from
the red portion of carbamoyl phosphate
which of course is this ammonium ion
here this carbon dioxide this amino
group here is
blue it's actually the same as this blue
amino group here from aspartate so
something to keep in mind and I'll talk
about the specific reactions of the urea
cycle in the next video so how is this
urea once it's created in the liver how
is it excreted well I wrote here made
here so it's obviously gonna start in
the liver it's going to go to the blood
which is good because urea is
water-soluble in the blood is mostly
water we mentioned that earlier
let's close to the blood it goes to the
kidneys because the kidneys are involved
in excreting waste products and urine is
produced and then urine is what we
release or excrete to the outside of our
bodies some some urea is also excreted
in sweat
so you can sweat out urine not urine you
sweat out urea I hope that video was a
helpful introduction to the urea cycle
one last thing I'm a tutor if you live
in Southern California feel free to
contact me via email at MOOC University
at gmail.com for more details check out
the description below thanks for
watching